if she tries to make it seem as if it
never happened or be like oh no it
wasn't me it was you kind of thing like
a reverse role-play title yeah yeah yeah
yeah dashing the chips and dipping yeah
no excuse no reason i have no reason to
give her i couldn't care less you know
me sometimes i couldn't care you'll walk
out
[Music]
i'm here for that
smooth
i see the rock keeps his [ __ ] cold oh
yeah of course he's cold of course he
does bro you don't play about the rock
knows class
he actually knows the rock knows class
he knows the difference um
oh my days that's just that's a that's a
thought actually we were having this
discussion every day was if if you had
to um play one drake song yeah to a
complete alien to sell them on drake
yeah what would it be oh
see the thing with me and drake right i
love the drake songs that don't have
choruses they just rap so fast exactly
do not disturb for example 4 p.m in
calabasas do you know the sub is
ignorant [ __ ] with um
lil
[Applause]
[Music]
one song he's got a catalogue fam is
tough he's got a catalogue tough bro
but i would probably go
i'd probably have to say 4pm only
because we even think we've been singing
it now 4pm is is live it's such a banger
it is it's such a wavy oh like you can't
help but bop me it came with a ha ha ha
ha ha
ha
yo he threw it back bro he threw it back
bro bro what a track
i remember when i remembered the first
time i heard that song actually i heard
it i'm pretty sure it came out came out
around christmas time in like 2016.
either 2015 or 2016 because i remember i
was walking to a shop
it was on christmas evil christmas day
and it was the only shop that was open
because there were muslims they didn't
obviously yeah everyone else closes yeah
and they were muslims so they were the
only ones open i remember i was banging
that track
to the shop i don't know what i was
going there for but i just remember the
time it was i was like this is a song
bro he's got a cato log the other day i
was um
so to your point when jay asked me
i did a few
but one of them was um do not destroy
disturb what that's a that's amazing
it's an amazing song
um december got pictures with me smiling
though jeez
yeah yeah gene ggg
what a banger um but then
another one that i wouldn't i've ever
picked before yeah i did a i did a re-up
on views the other day okay
but views bang it does bang it does bang
fire and desire fire and desire bangs
nine bangs i'm gonna listen to that in a
minute um
uh
flipping what what one uh oh don't do
this to me let me play there's two that
i've been smashing out i'll pull up the
catalog now um it's uh
ah
it's flipping oh don't do this to me man
it's fine brother we got here we got it
i've been banging it all week
all right work there
western road flows no that's another one
that i like western road
[ __ ] for my [ __ ] chorus
yeah
it is child's play or grammys no you
with me
oh yes on some dmx [ __ ] yes fam yes
you with me is one but the other one the
loki one is still here
as a hype track
bro when the when the bass hits i'm
still here
i'm still here dog
oh
when i'm back dog
oh
you just went and turned your back dog
ah bro
it's hard i haven't heard that in a
minute it's hard to listen to this album
in a minute bro the album banks faithful
as well with pimpsy yeah yeah
i want bangs that does bang
bro you with me is a is a
song yeah top tier you can't really
can't really argue about that bro man
makes two iphone references in that song
i can't remember so uh yeah the iphone
cracks iphone five six no no no no no no
no no that's a different track oh is it
this one is the one that you have to
it's one of them ones where it's like uh
if you don't own an iphone you're not
gonna know these tracks okay okay um but
man's like when you talk about beefing
with his goal and was like um
all that grey in our conversation
history you playing man games when
you're saying things and then he says
about the uh triple dot
three dots you're thinking of a reaction
still oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but tell me why you're
thinking
well games have a game of being played
how's it going down if something to
become the gondola now is it with me or
what
and then the ending from
i've got responsibilities the people
that i needed
he was on his knees hands and knees he's
on his hands and knees mike just here
oh
i tried to kill you as the world you
running your fingers to my curls you
knew me when the kid had waves
but i said you could never say i came up
and forgot about your ass oh bro
yeah using his hands and knees crying
wow but yeah i feel like i'd have to
sorry to cut you off obviously because
you asked me that question and we were
just um singing in 4pm in calabasas
before this episode just dropped or
before this episode started my
instinctive brain was like 4pm but i
have to go through his catalogue i think
bro there's so many more bangers bro jay
was bringing up ones that like i haven't
thought about in years i can imagine fan
man press play all of hers
[Music]
bro oh trophies that's a tune
that's a huge i've heard that in ages
that would make me smack a stranger
ah i do not know about the
intercontinental bro wow
tune yeah jake's the guy
speaking of musicians i was thinking
about this yesterday
t-pain doesn't get enough flowers
t-pain back in our day 10 11 12 years
ago i don't know how however old you
guys are but t-pain back in the day was
one of the
best musicians going like
feature tracks everything he was he was
top three men
top three he was three oh my god
one slept on you that i used to love um
him and akon i can't wait have you heard
that song i probably have black i can't
so the reason why the reason why i was
thinking about him um when i when it
came to mind yesterday is because
i
listened to have you heard his new track
with kalani i like it i like that maybe
i like that so he sampled the fir
sample buy you a drink
on his own track yeah yeah so obviously
as soon as you hear that that takes you
back bro 10 15 years ago way back and
it's just a great memory great vibes
great and you just remember t-pain was
the guy bro t-pain was the [ __ ] guy
and man was dropping banger off the
banger of the banger but then he had a
hiatus everyone knew he kind of like
fell off a bit don't know why but then
he came back with
booty going
i dare you not to go off bro i dare you
not to go off bro um he's got some
interesting stories as well because he's
on twitch now did you know yes stays on
twitter have you heard he's like he's
opening raptor twitch no no i've not
seen any but i know he's on twitch
because i've seen it on there but i've
never seen it bro let me try and find
his opening on on on twitch
fam i can imagine
oh he was such
but whilst you're finding that my point
was
i feel like he doesn't get enough
flowers because for him to sample buy
you a drink obviously when you hear that
it's very classic and everyone knows
that that was a banger back in the day
so him to sample it and still make it
work
and still make you
not think it's just about buy you a
drink but he made the actual song yeah
banger he's a he is a he's a real one
he's a real one bro he doesn't get
enough flowers he doesn't he's pain is
hard yeah this is how man's starting off
his streams oh sick
[Music]
i think i have seen this
i've seen a version of it
[Music]
tonight but feel free to host me i'm a
big brainer
pro gamer other channels lamos they know
namers five sub 20 subs
cause it won't fit in
i stay loyal to my brailles and you know
i can't
yeah i think i've seen that because that
the first like four bars ring a belt so
i'll be hyped um but on twitch he's done
a few things where he's told like
stories and stuff like that okay and
he's talking about when he signed with
acon okay
and he was saying he got offered a
a ridiculous contract with someone else
okay
um but it was
for
ah i can't remember they wanted a song
i can't remember one of his writes to
one of yours they wanted they wanted him
for one song basically okay they wanted
him to release
whatever song this was whether it was
buy your drink or one of them originals
they wanted to sign him
and that to be his first single release
under that label basically buy your
drink or bartender yeah i think it was
bartender actually um oh yeah maybe yeah
yeah yeah or what's the next one i'm a
level of stripper
was that the first one banger banger in
it
banger
the remix with like r kelly
so it was one of them
basically it was like for a mil or two
mil okay he was a teenager okay he was
young yeah
um and then
basically acorn came up to me and said i
want to sign you but i can only afford
to give you x amount x amount wasn't
even lost it was a lot less bro it was
it wasn't much at all i think it was
like 50k or something like that 100k
maybe
um and then i could be butchering it but
it was low yeah yeah yeah um and he said
but i want to make you an artist fam
i want to make you an artist sick and
deeply like gang let's do it sick turn
down the the millions
gang let's do it econ said i'm going to
make you an artist bro
and he did he did man bro
yeah i forget a considerable yeah bro
they can have the vision yeah he didn't
have the vehicle he's a businessman he
is a savage business he's out here doing
business yeah i know he wants to make
like senegal next thing yeah he's trying
to make senegal next thing
he is he was trying to build a city no
yes of course
i've seen like a solar pan a solar
powered
solar panel powered sea yeah ridiculous
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's actually doing
next thing but yeah he signed him and
said that um and there was another thing
i think it was kanye what i think it
might not been kanye west but it was
someone on kanye's level okay i said
that he was talking about the first time
that they ever met and he was guest to
meet him and stuff like that okay and he
this is t-pain
in him so it may have been kanye may
have been someone else yeah for some
reason it's kind of my head but um he
basically went up to him and was like oh
cool nice to meet he was like oh gang
yeah nice to meet you too everyone was
pleasant he was like ah um
you do know you've killed music
he told c pain but yeah the person
whether it's kind of like said you've
killed music oh wow just so you know
because it's all because t-pain set
auto-tune yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean you've killed music forever just
know that like you're live but just know
music's dead because of you jesus and he
deepens it at the time he just brushed
it off like [ __ ] off like your hate or
whatever then like
after sitting down
he was thinking [ __ ] have i killed music
have i actually destroyed music because
now it doesn't matter
because deeply can actually sing you can
actually sing of course but it's like it
doesn't matter anymore doesn't matter if
you're singing what's up you can't
because everyone's on auto now almost
everyone's gone auto tuned yeah yeah
damn imagine hearing that from one of
your idols damn
but i feel like
tough criticism like that is the reason
probably why he's an idol you know oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's say it was
kind of for example kanye west is very
outspoken he speaks his mind yeah and
i'm assuming t-pain as a growing artist
at the time like you said he brushed it
off but it would have come a stage where
he feels like
let's say he was kind of kanye said that
for a reason you know he wasn't trying
to diminish who he was as an artist but
just let you know big man you're great
but you [ __ ] up yeah you've earned it
forever you're doing it for everyone
yeah and it's something you have to take
on the chain you know because kanye
again is a visionary thinker yeah
thought processor so yeah man i can
understand i can understand that yeah
that was like um with a obviously not as
deep as as you've killed music but i
remember because j cole had that track
let nars down in it yeah man said nas
was this guy forever yeah yeah finally
met him and he's like you're hard but
that
because was it work out for me i think
it was work out it's like that workout
tune is [ __ ]
[ __ ] like what actually is that so what
are you doing
what are you actually doing damn
the thing i i think that track is back
in obviously from nasa's perspective
nars knows a lot more about music than i
do
but i think that's banging i think the
track's banging it is a bang in tune but
i i think what nasa's trying to say is
that's not you
it's so painfully obvious that's a cash
grab song of course because that's a pop
song first major single yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um what were the what was these mixtapes
before then uh
come up the camera
yes yeah yeah i don't think he was
wrapping his arse off
he was grinding
speaking of j cole i was doing like a
little throwback sorry to cut you off
i was doing like a little throwback
thing spotify comes up with like loads
of like old-school playlists and stuff
and do you remember a star is born um
jay-z j cole every day
yeah i remember i remember remember
i do remember now you just did the
platform nicole's verse in that trap
roll he's hard
oh
i was like because i remember i heard
that song i think i was in year
maybe 12 or 13 when that album dropped
and i heard that first time i was
thinking wow
what a verse yeah that's a [ __ ] yes
um that's when i was like yeah jayco
you're you're the guy but then i sorry
it's quite your thing but i can now
thinking back to that i can understand
why
um nars said oh the workout track
yeah i think the reason he was saying it
i think the perspective he was putting
on it was basically how anyone else
would feel if nars made that workout
song
okay
regardless of his bang like if nas made
that's all everywhere everyone's like
what are you doing what are you doing
big man you are
put down the pom-poms g make the make
the real music yeah okay so that i think
that's what he was trying to say to jay
carl okay like that's petty family what
are you doing that's not you don't beg
it don't make it it's a banger but it
doesn't matter i beg it for the people
yeah it's a club tuning fan what are you
doing yeah yeah but then yeah jacob
makes
bangers he does make bangers um i went
back and listened to
what was it
one song that i remember back then was
one that made me think that ra but it's
not one of the ones that typically
people would think okay jacob yeah j
cole on born sinner
um it's a light one is she gone pop do
you remember that one you'd have to i
remember the track um
where her [ __ ] went yeah i do guess as
good as mine it was probably one of the
ones that i didn't like always like yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a skip over time
have a skipper thing or when you're
playing albums like yeah it's cool yeah
it's a light one fan but for me that one
i just love the flow in that one okay i
love that and it's a story story if you
actually listen to it in the lyrics it's
a story story he's a storyteller that's
why i do love jake yeah and i remember
uh when i was listening to i was
thinking god everyone's sleeping on this
song this sounds bad
and i used to feel that way with um
he had that song it reminded me it was
like a tyler-esque song okay because
it's like stalkerish okay um
on this is the girl on my dreams
and it's as good as what she seems
uh but it's about a girl that he fancies
he's just like following her around to
her work and all that stuff to find out
that she's got like she's got next man
or something like tyler she in it yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah i remember that song i was like
this is a banger but again it was one of
the ones that everyone used to just like
oh yes cool and then skip on but yeah i
loved that song but i feel because i
think at that time
because remember j cole has been rapping
for 13 14 years so obviously when we got
first introduced him in uni
it was all about the bangers it's all
about what pops
[Music]
that's why workout banged for us at our
age whereas nasa was like that's not you
big man yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah rap
yeah don't dance with me rap for me you
know
don't dance for man rap for me you know
prove your worth for me yeah yeah yeah
yeah back in those days that's what was
what even still now some more time
sometimes you need to sometimes you need
a cup of tea yeah yeah yeah yeah to
raise your profile and obviously that
was his first thing i think that was his
first single workout his first proper
single winner it was definitely his
first club you won
but like pre-mixtapes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was his first
banger yeah so i can understand the fact
that
we all needed at that point club bangers
all the time but that's probably the
reason why a lot of these songs got
slept on because people aren't checking
for that yeah that's your time people
want to bop yeah yeah they ain't got
time for that the deep stuff they
haven't got time for it time for that
but the more and more you listen to j
cole and the more you go obviously j
cole now is classed as one of the best
lyricists in the world so when you go
back and listen to his old stuff you
appreciate the old stuff that's what i
do with drake as well sometimes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was having this
conversation in the car with um
tobes and fatal um talking about the
clarity of musicians nowadays
and the reason why dave's doing so well
because
the clarity you can hear everything he
says yeah by storms he's doing so well
but people like getz for example
gets raps very very fast and likes a lot
of things will go over
but because i listen to that kind of
music i hear everything he gets says but
he will never be as popular as they are
100 purely because dave's clarity is
just second to none yeah
yeah yeah with drake yeah that's the
reason why these men are excelling you
know i don't know
i
i understand why those guys are the
goats in there that makes sense you know
that being said
with that i'm gonna get slapped for this
the storms eating you see how you said
our team paint doesn't get enough
flowers
in my opinion storms it gets way too
many flowers okay and it makes me hate
him and it's not even his fault okay but
he gets so many flowers in this country
anyway okay that i'm just like enough
okay like i just i don't know it's
there's nothing that he's ever made that
i've heard that i've been like that's
[ __ ] prolific
the heavy is the head that what heavy is
the hair disease most recent album yeah
which came out a few years ago i don't i
don't i'm not banged that album but i've
listened to that yeah yeah but i've
followed kind of followed storms career
yeah from like shut up and all of that
bro right wicked game men part three all
of that stuff but when it comes to his
features
because i listen to storms yeah the
features the things he says bro yeah the
word play the clarity like i said again
the clarity i understand why storms is
up there fair play people like chip for
example chip has been
around as long as god he's been around
for like 15 16 years
since i was in secondary school yeah
since i was his second year chip's been
spitting and he like he said he never
runs out of bars that's why that's one
of these most prolific buzz i never run
out of bars but
because
he again for me because i listen to him
and follow him for me what he says is
clear like this clarity but because he's
not looking to
sell out and like go into this
mainstream world he just makes music for
him and he's yeah
his fans
he will never be as globally accepted as
all these other people yeah man this i
understand where you're coming from in
terms of the storms eating because like
i said i don't really
for me that album wasn't like a prolific
album like you said but i know storms
he's got what it takes
i listen to him and like his features
and all of that are just so so so good
so good and he does a lot i think the
reason why storms is also out there he
does a lot for the community he does a
lot for black people
you know it's it's more it's not just
about the music for stormzy yeah and
that's the reason why he's i believe
he's escalated as far as he has if that
makes sense i could be completely wrong
that was but that's my assumption that
was a monologue magic fair play yeah
yeah he's thinking about you for that
he should hear that thank you you know i
do i do hear that though but yeah man
yeah for me i
obviously i don't
i don't look for his music but obviously
you can't not hear a lot of it yeah yeah
yeah um and everything i've ever heard
of his
obviously it's enjoyable it's fine yeah
yeah yeah but considering he gets like
in a lot of circles gets like he's just
like you said like oh you've got drake
you've got storms either and then he
actually gets that kind of recognition
and for me personally obviously i'm just
like
i don't [ __ ] get it yeah yeah i don't
[ __ ] get it like to me it's just any
artist to me like i've never thought our
banger
obviously i thought yeah cool but like
never ever
ever ever thought
i'm happy this guy's i'm happy this guy
is getting like the love that he's
getting because like he deserves it i'm
just like i hear you i do hear but then
obviously that goes that depends on how
much you listen to someone strange again
is understandable it's true like
the i don't know if you know but maybe
two
maybe like two years ago
him and chip were in a back-to-back beef
um and if they were dropping they were
dropping um tracks on youtube like maybe
it was two years ago yeah yeah earlier
you're dropping traps on youtube chip
i've always rated chip like he's bars
and everything anything chip spits on is
always fire but again when it comes to
the clarity like i said stormzy there
was i can't remember what the tracks are
called but i can remember seeing the
videos in my head he did one in tokyo
and he did another one and he did when
he he was beefing
his face is in my head it's not lethal
ism wiley oh yeah he had a back and
forth with wiley as well bro
some of the but i can't remember now
obviously yeah when i when i think about
it back or when i think about it when i
was listening to at the time i was
thinking yo storms you're you're a
lyricist bro that's fair you could i
heard once i heard that he was taking
time to come out with him he was he was
she was coming next day chip is that's
the thing with chip chip is
a real emcee yeah
that's what i'm saying but he's never
going to get the flowers that yeah yeah
that's what chips on chips on smoke and
it's a fact he's on small
but if it comes to
when it comes to like the household name
storms he's just bigger than you yeah
and it's just a fact yeah you just have
to you just have to hold that up yeah
yeah but it's a shame
it's a shame because chip's been in the
game longer than storms from time
bro um that album he did with the all
the american dance he did with chris
brown and all them a lot it's called
champion yeah that came in like 2012.
man went fully pop but it's still bang
you got on the track with trey songz
chris brown so many american artists
what about that [ __ ] um
mavardo
was it every girl i mad
wow bro
bro chip's done stuff in this game yeah
he has he's done stuff in this game yeah
she has i forgot all you got science ti
that was it that's how he got he got
propelled into the american american um
genre in american like world and stuff
he got signed to ti's label what's it
called like grand hustle or hustle i
can't remember it's called but that's
the reason why he got propelled into
that aspect
but i think that fell off and he came
back to his uk roots and then he just
started dropping and dropping and
dropping
but there was a bar he said where um
chip the artist or chip the mc which one
is that but i can take it he said i
can't remember which track it was but he
said i have a raw whichever chip you
want i can bring it i can still deliver
because he can
chip can bro
but storms these flowers are they're
bigger than these they're bigger than
chips
because i feel like they're both great
mcs but yeah we're just rambling of our
artists now that's the car man i'm i'm
in the zone now oh you i love music bro
you said
you said that's a good shape to really
if chip hears his name in someone else's
track he's already got his pen and paper
he's already got his pen and paper he's
ready to scrap he's ready to scrap
that's the thing that's why i love chip
because
he
knows he can go toe-to-toe with anyone
he knows yeah he knows he's waiting to
hear him he's waiting for someone to
send for him he doesn't need to send
anymore
you know yeah and bro you gotta give him
the flowers for that yeah because he
comes correct every single time yeah
every single time true true true
it's true but that's another thing as
well that's another thing as well when
you to go back to the the wily thing
yeah
why deserves every flower everything
yeah yeah why do you never grow up he's
a pioneer
because that's kind of what started off
his beef before isn't it what do you
mean he was just getting not slept on
but basically
he just wasn't getting the love
and he was trying to he was he was out
he's screaming like you might don't even
know who i am
he's the younger generation but jensen
didn't rate him
they didn't rate him he's getting
laughed at i'm thinking why you're 40.
big wiley coyote
when i was a kid i wanted to smoke and
when i heard you just getting laughed at
laughter
i wanted to fight his corner
youngers don't understand they don't get
it they don't understand who this is
and that reminded me of when people like
you can talk to like older people now
especially if you're talking about like
old school hip-hop
and they'll bring out names yeah yeah
that you're just like please shut up
yeah like if anyone's obviously you know
their point is but when they're just
like our ice cube
um and just like i know what you mean
public enemies
it's not on the level that it needs to
be and you're like
and you can tell they want to smack you
in your face because it's way before our
time way before our time waiver time and
then anything that's made now is based
on the back of that
and then just like yeah but like these
artists have got all these things to go
from they can sample whatever they want
these my back had nothing nothing and
this was the fire they were coming out
with that's very true bro all these
drake songs that we love he's samples
galore that's very true he samples got
lore kanye kendrick all of them they're
doing
and then they get all the love
things in my back here just just broke
because there was no internet back then
there was no there was none of that
technology back there truly there was
none of that back then because when i
find out i can't i can't think of an
example right now but when i
listen to a banger by drake or j cole or
kendrick or someone like that in our era
for example and i realized the song has
been sampled from like the 1980s i'm
like wow
wow speaking of speaking of there is
there's a few of these but there's one
guy on tick tock
i think i know that he does whose sample
to you like you wouldn't believe who
this you never believe this or something
yeah yeah absolutely there's a few of
them but there's have you seen this guy
he's like he's a mask no
see yeah i know which one you're talking
about this guy he's got a smooth mellow
tone okay he's just like some tall white
guy okay and um
like he's got a deep voice the american
guy deep voice and he's like you're
welcome back to uh you never believe it
was sampled part 100 he had
hundreds of them and some of them are so
obvious but there's some of them
some of them and you're just like okay
cool so you take this beat and it's just
like some any
beat from the [ __ ]
temptations yeah yeah yeah yeah and or
earth window fire or some [ __ ] yeah and
then you're like all right calling they
double speed it and they reverb it and
they miss it and then that and you're
like
where are you going with this bro and
then they did do it and then you're like
bro you hear it you can hear it you
could hear it yeah yeah [ __ ] hell
like
how bro how is that even the daft punk
do that on bits
daft punk they do that on on crack
yes they do
the
was it get lucky or whatever it's called
what's that what the pharrell one it's
darpan feature referral right yeah yeah
they sampled i'm sure they sampled that
really i think so i think i've seen oh
everything sampled out someone sampled
them because i've seen someone do a
sample with darth punk in it
it rings bell but i can't remember the
example i saw with the duff popcorn was
the um
oh no how does it go
it's like it's an old one
one more time yes i've seen that one
i've seen that one
yeah i think that's the one i was
talking about and that original was
sort of like the 60s yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right mad mad
mad
but anyway we've done like half an hour
of um
lyricist [ __ ]
i have a fun fact basically it's kind of
a fun fact but it's basically like a
statement follow-up it's a statement
that i truly believe now followed up by
facts okay cool so the statement is
pandas you see you know how pandas are
endangered okay yeah yeah they deserve
to be
pandas deserve to be endangered to my g
they don't deserve to live
and that's i they don't want to live
because they're stupid pandas are stupid
pandas are stupid so facts about pandas
right
this is why they don't deserve to be
saved we're wasting resources on these
men and they don't want it for
themselves so if they don't want it for
themselves then why do we want it for
them yeah yeah why are we checking for
them
stupid bruv so first of all
their mating window
for the year is five days
no [ __ ] way five days out of the year
they [ __ ]
five days
pause imagine only having imagine only
being hauling for five days out of 365
days a year as human beings oh everyone
be in prison
if you're not into those five days
pen
murder
no one's going to work that way we
couldn't function as a society like that
everyone could stress it would literally
purge for five days it would be the
first nut
take someone's eye out yeah 100
you'll drown them
from the inside out it's disgusting
from the inside
um second so first of all they make they
they're making windows five days a year
jesus
man said and also on top of that they're
completely solitary which means they
live completely each and every
individual one live completely alone no
way which means in these five days they
they're just looking for man they don't
even know who's about
i can't believe that yeah fam so they
only make five days a year they're
completely solitary
the baby when it's born
is one nine hundredth the size of the
mum
wow one nine a small as hell and
whenever the mom gets hungry she just
leaves it
no so baby pandas get yammed for joke no
they're tiny little things and their mum
gets a little i don't know she gets
packaged and bounces doesn't bring to
you bounces says i'm starving just [ __ ]
off and gets food
for hours hours at a time no way leaves
a little you by itself course is going
to get backed
of course it's going to get backed
on young cobra just sliding through the
jungle is going to wholesome and oh
funny this is the fun fact
guess what the name do you know what the
name of a group of founders is called
i feel like i've seen it somewhere
definitely you must have seen it but for
the life of me i can't remember so you
will remind me
an embarrassment
that's what it's actually called a
couple of pandas is called an
embarrassment
i can't say it with a straight face a
group of pandas is called embarrassment
that is hilarious because it's so
coincidental bro
ah they're useless animals fam let them
die because they're not supposed to be
actually they climb trees and drop for
junk
they drop all have you never seen panda
videos of them just dropping
you've never seen that i don't watch
panda videos i've seen it on like
twitter and stuff yeah yeah i have to
just climb trees and just drop they're
the clumsiest animals
oh wow they're the clumsiest animals in
the world bro bro they need to
bro they need to drop like the dodo
they need to be done
clumsy panda clumsy pandas falling all
right bet
oh i've seen this one on twitter for
sure [ __ ] advert
because they got fun there's charities
for these men oh yeah fully fledged
licensed charities begging me for money
they say these things they don't want to
save themselves
let me see you [ __ ]
fam
these men are idiots yeah they're
useless
they just fall from the highest yeah
they're fully they're fully useless
to be fair so a human's family we fall
daily
to be fair
but daily i think i was gonna say i
think the thing with us the reason why
it's different is because we can
comprehend what's right and wrong but
then again pandas all animals probably
can comprehend what's right and wrong oh
yeah you know but obviously i'm not a
pandas i don't know i'm assuming it's
true um anyway you said you had a
scenario yes [ __ ] i forgot about that
it's more of a is a scenario what would
you do kind of thing yeah yeah
so
remember
weeks and months ago i um i was reading
this confession box thing
um like where someone said like it was
on instagram and someone sent us a
random scenario bro like it was more
like sexual orientation i remember yeah
so boom
wasn't the night out with the girls to
get my mind off my ex who had recently
cheated on me having a fab light having
a fab night drinks were coming the
atmosphere was good dancing and
generally having a blast one fella
caught my eye and i saw him have a look
too
as the night went on looks and smiles
were exchanged and towards the end of
the night he approached me and we ended
up leaving to get a mackies sounds
perfect already in it i can see your
lips it sounds perfect it's already in
it i can imagine
myself skipping the map i can imagine
myself in the darts already exchanging
looks of pleasantries yeah yeah yeah
yeah you wouldn't be exchanging nothing
you'll hold the eye contact probably i
hold like i love eye contact i love you
i can't see you man if you could ever
see foo head in a club yeah when he's on
the prowl oh my days it's
concerning
he does not blink when he sees the girl
he likes he does not blink or move or
nothing
bro eye contact is for me is so sexy bro
i love it it makes my blood boil but in
a good way yeah yeah if you're staring
straight and you're not staring at me if
we're out together and you're staring
straight and your face is straight i
already know what you're doing before i
look yeah you know what you're doing and
i could be talking to you you weren't
looking at me i won't be looking at me
looking through you bro
i'm looking at a spice
but yeah anyway funny carry on yeah and
i'm gonna read it up a bit so as the
night went on looks were looks and
smiles were exchanged and towards the
end of the night he approached me and we
ended up leaving to get mackies
was all going well we ordered some food
and he must have complimented me about
10 times like telling me i was the best
looking girl he saw in a club
proceeding to act shy and cute i
accidentally snorted and just my luck
the biggest booger fell out my nose flew
out of my nose and into his fries
he was so absolutely mortified and it
was safe to say we called it at night
and he never saw me again fam what would
you do if you're the guy
what do you do you secured you and her
have exchanged pleasantries bro you've
had a cheeky grin a cheeky smile a
cheeky wine a cheeky dance you guys have
grabbed a drink
she's paying bro how hang is she fam
she's paying she's paying she's like a a
nice eight like you don't know her so
she's a nice eight out of ten you don't
know what she looks like outside of work
she's a nice eight out of ten on the
night she's feeling you you're feeling
her bro
like boom boom boom let's leave early
i'm hungry she's like she says i'm
hungry let's grab a mackie's and you
know you love her maki's after a dunya
hot chips hot chips yeah bro hot chips
on a burger yeah we're there
i know we we've served on it many times
we love mcdonald's after after a dance
she offers euro let's go mcdonald's i'm
hungry roll and we're like you guys dip
boom boom boom boom
you man are skipping in mcdonald's what
should i get what should i get you all
you're you're having giggles on the
autumn but you're clicking the automatic
it's just clicking she's clicking for
you you're trying to remove
i'll be texting you
you like that
you'll be in the shrimp tell me just
shut up
that's too funny because it's so true oh
um so yeah
so you get your food now you guys are
talking talking so you bust one i don't
know you bust a joke that means doki
joke giggle
into your chip you're you're mid like
eating like you know
you're there you're there you just see
it slow-mo bang
lands into the middle of your hot fries
what do you do right what do you do it's
dread all right cool
for me as i was hearing it this one's
actually kind of like a no-brainer for
me okay so
if i thought she was paying enough that
i would actually want to see her again
after today
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
okay about the booger thing i wouldn't
give a single [ __ ] okay
um
yeah i literally wouldn't care that
makes sense but if she's just a thing
that i just want to
[ __ ] smash
like she's like she's not someone i
would ever really go for and i have no
interest in seeing it again after today
but she's just got a body
or something she's got something that's
appealing
like i know she slops a nasty tool like
this is about to be a and like a
disgusting one night bang and then i'm
out of there okay if i'm thinking i'm
already not sleeping here tonight yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is
all it would take for me to like dash a
chips in her face and walk out
100
if i thought i don't even find it's got
that attractive but she just looks like
she's
she's
nasty yeah she slops her tongue she
slops the top
and then i make a little jokey joke and
she
laughs and it's not all over my food i
will launch it in her face and i'll walk
out some but it's one of them ones where
booger goes into the chip but there's
also a booger down yeah because it's too
much
your mood would change your burner would
subside but you'll see me back in the
shrubs in 10.
you'll see me back in the dance in ten
look at my background
nibbler
that is hilarious bro yeah if she was
just a nut that's all it would take for
me to move that or a fart
or something like that maybe even a wet
burp
get out my face what's a wet burp like a
like a sicky bird
i know what you mean i know what you
mean one that you couldn't do with your
mouth closed one kind of one mm-hmm i
know exactly yeah yeah it sounded like a
little gargle on the end of it get the
[ __ ] out of it
that or that's all it would take bro
that's all it would take with me it's
hilarious with me if i don't actually
find that girl like very attractive
bro honestly
the smaller things turned me off yeah
smaller if i saw like a weird streak of
tan on the back of her leg
done
done i know what you mean she's wearing
heels and i can see like a black heel
like the the her football is because
she's been walking barefoot you know
she's been walking but oh that's one of
my pets bro we could be walking down the
road and a [ __ ] ankle twist slightly
to the left fat
i'm done no i'm done i can hold yourself
together babes yeah hold yourself
together we've all had a few drinks yeah
if it's just a slanting anything can put
me off anything could put me off i just
don't know when it's gonna happen yeah
yeah yeah yeah
don't know what is gonna happen i can
look at the back of the head and just
see like a little clump
i'm out
arm
out bro anything can put me off okay
let's say it wasn't a bugger thing let's
say it wasn't it wasn't as obvious as a
booger and for example you saw like a
heel back you clearly can tell she's
been walking barefoot how would you
leave the situation
scenario you're playing for mcdonald's
you're both ordering food everything's
going well there's no booger you're
having a great conversation and just one
of the small things put me on one of the
small things put you off how are you
leaving how are you patting in there so
you can go because you obviously now
you're not sexually frustrated by her
yeah and i'm just gonna go back probably
get back in the dark
if i leave now have another lap have
another round um
i would probably
because i don't want to lie i don't want
to say oh i just [ __ ] leave out
because i'm too scared to do that i
don't know what's going to come after um
i would probably
knowing me
pretend that you've called me um
you would bail me oh whatever you're
pretending to know i believe i
and then i'd be like hello and you're
like what do you want from
what
sorry about one sec
what do you mean
who
yeah yeah but no not the normal barbecue
the smoky one the twenty twenty
but just say it with confidence and they
might give you for free hang on
a man's mcdonald's he's there he's at
the counter
yo hang on i'm still here i'm still here
i'm saying yeah
yeah can we do nine instead of six all
right say let's say yes say bet yeah
um yeah
this one
um bro honestly
are you alone
you're not alone
keep the receipt
um
bro you know what oh [ __ ] um i'm just
trying to think because i'm with
kelly
um
bro i know i know i know i know don't
move don't move you know what don't move
don't move don't move um
bro it's not far it's not far i'll tell
you what yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna call
you back in two minutes i'm gonna call
you back in two minutes
babe i gotta go
i'm literally gonna be back in five yeah
so that's in trouble trouble
you're not gonna be able to keep up in
these hills stay here enjoy your meal
have mine whatever yeah yeah this is
look at you you're painting
painting
painting make us smile because yeah yeah
yeah
trust me i'm gonna be back painting
you're gonna get scared
you little knives
oh
i'll dip and i'll never return you'll
never see her again 100 i'm never
returning oh that's hilarious well
thought though but that's hilarious
that's hilarious brother i love that
what are you doing fam i don't know if
she's paying with the booger thing if
she's paying oh so the booger scenario
we're going back okay and then we'll
transform it
ah
i don't know it depends on how she plays
it off
because obviously we both know this book
of things happened it also depends on
whether one she tries to ignore that it
happened or she embraces that happens
and we laughed about it yeah because if
she tries to ignore it and we both know
what happened
i have to i have to make it known that
i'm never going to eat these chips again
you know yeah yeah
i have to let her know that big man did
you just see what happened like are we
not going to address this i'm not trying
to embarrass you but you saw this happen
it came out from you you know
you have to say sign yeah at least i'm
sorry let me run you another chippy yeah
yeah yeah 100 yeah you can't ignore it
you can't get embarrassed you have to
chest you have to chest it because we're
here now you need to you need to know
your pen you're paying it in this booger
exactly don't let the booger beat you
exactly don't let the gaze so if the
booger beats her and she doesn't embrace
the situation i mean like
what's going on big babes you're just
[ __ ] snotting in my chips you ever
run me another one
or i need to bounce because this is an
on
this is an on
but if she rolls up to me and embraces
him like oh my [ __ ] days i am so
sorry blah blah she just burst out
laughing maybe she was pissing us out
chasing herself she's laughing
mean you told the kids like how did we
meet uh funny story guys funny i thought
it was a smash thing and she snotted on
my chest
it's not even here you are yeah i never
wanted anyone else ever again bro so it
has to be one of them things it depends
on how she reacts to the situation 100
so if she embraces it and we laugh about
it i'm gonna keep the night moving with
her
if she tries to make it seem as if it
never happened or be like oh no it
wasn't me it was you kind of thing like
a reverse role-play tip yeah yeah yeah
yeah dashing the chips and dipping yeah
no excuse no reason i have no reason to
give her i couldn't care less you know
me sometimes i couldn't care
i'll walk away she'll be talking you
just look back
she can she'll bop toilet she'll never
see me again
she will never see me again god
that's true because we've not exchanged
numbers at this point we've just bought
mcdonald's yeah you've never seen that
it's done a dirty heel back she'll never
see me again
oh yeah for me bro yeah it's literally a
case of if she's banging banging she
owns it
bro we're cool we're still going back to
yard after 100 bro but if you
if you try and lie to me or if you let
this if yeah if you let the shame of
this not defeat you yeah you're done
you're done out here bro you're done
here bro
yeah 100 and yeah to me even to be fair
if and but that's if she's paying if
she's just a banker i said seven eight
she has to be paid yeah she's just a
banking i don't care if she owns it i
don't care what happens i'm gone
fam to me if the figures naughty yeah
i know for you i know for you
licking chicken type thing yeah i don't
know i know for you i know you'll put up
with a lot fam i'm gonna i'll go to the
toilet and grab a tissue
not me bro i'll dash my chips like babes
i need to get you a t-shirt because this
isn't running yeah
let's clean up and let's dip yeah you're
i'm not yeah yeah no not me
yeah i know it doesn't take i i'm
shallow when it comes to my one-night
stands i'm shadow fan and it doesn't
take you much to leave it doesn't take
anything i know what you mean
i'll lose a bonus that i don't know what
you mean oh it's done but then i don't
like especially if i know
this can potentially lead to like great
sex and if i think she's either 7 out of
10 banging or physique-wise she's just
meat for me like she's lunch for me yeah
yeah and it's reciprocated like i'm
lunch for her yeah
if it's that kind of sexual vibe
it will take a lot for it to ruin my
mojo
yeah like but that depends for me for me
to look at because that's the thing like
for for it to just be a bang thing
the way i'm talking
i'm not even looking at her like
none of that
because i'm not eating pump i'm not
doing nothing like i know what you mean
i'm just talking about she is just like
foundation level
just hot enough to bang
uh okay and i was just trying to pattern
the end of the night smash that's it if
i'm looking at things like
i'm this is lunch
i'm looking for a great time yeah then
yeah you want to
yeah yeah yeah
happily happily that the book of things
but then again
obviously we've had two sipses but at
the end of that mcdonald's now you've
probably had bag of drinks yeah jd's
have got like true your your mindset is
different true and when we're drunk bro
our tools speak for themselves true
mutual might not give a [ __ ] do you know
what i mean my all might not give you
speaks for themselves bro
my patrol probably thinking i wish she
snotted on me
some nasty names
she's a nasty that's my drunk mind's
crazy as well my drug mine's crazy with
hard tool and drunk head she'll snotting
up she's a nasty she's a nasty [ __ ]
nasty [ __ ]
come here yeah
you filthy little slack
come here
where's your apartment that's scary man
come on
let's grab these chips and dip
because i'm blosky oh that's hilarious
bro oh
that is [ __ ] that's too funny man
[ __ ] b oh okay cool that's gang for me
i've got one's got we we had a few
people sending one's got to go oh i
forgot about that they're tame they're
hell attained but they're like yeah
they're they're just well it's just a
one-off thing okay
it's just nice it's just i liked it
um okay cool so
this one i'll go with this one
one's got to go
jim
this is interesting one fine dining
[Applause]
gym fine dining clubs
or holidays
that's tough yeah it's all over the shop
that's tough that's that's different
levels of enjoyment to me that dopamine
is different for each one yeah exactly
so gym fine dining clubs and holidays
i mean i think right what forever [ __ ]
i love
fine dining because obviously what i do
i appreciate great service i appreciate
good food i understand what it takes to
provide this level of service yes bro
you know what i mean yeah
but i love going out i've not been out
obviously i've not had a great night out
since amsterdam which was 20
to february 2020. i've not been fed 20
20 yeah i've not been out since then i
think i'm going to go out this weekend
actually is it i think so because the
way my shift pattern patterns i think
i'm out tonight oh i say tonight i think
i'm out this weekend i think this
weekend so we'll see but i'm not but i
am but
i would have
it could never be holidays i love going
away even though i don't go away that
often i still like embrace it
it can never be jim because jim is jim
is life gym with solidarity you know
yeah
it might have to be fine as much as as
much as i know it brings to the table
brings to my table
i can't get rid of clubs bro yeah i'm
not in me i can't get rid of jim and i
can't get rid of holidays i know what
you mean it would have to be the fine
dining what about you that's a good one
it is good that made me think
for me
it would have to be
either
fine dining or holidays
and i love holidays okay so why holidays
because i haven't been on holiday
in ages now i know i neither have i but
i know the feeling of going away
especially with people that you love you
around you know i miss the feeling i do
miss it so imagine never having that
again exactly um but like say we're
going out tonight yeah and i know the
food is fine
and i'm giddy yeah okay i'm kidding i
know what you mean i can i don't want to
ever not have this feeling ever again oh
oh you've made me think a lot more now
purely because find a fine dining
experience can happen week and week out
whereas a holiday will never happen week
and week out yes once it's probably like
three four i say three four times a year
maybe
one or two times a year yeah you know
depending on your social status your
financial status
you don't go on holiday week and week
out whereas you can have a good fine
dining experience week and week out
for it but then again
it's always there holidays are a week
plus
finding is two hours
i think for me it still has to be fine
dining yeah i think i think in the end
i'll pick fine darling to go
um
i'll miss it but yeah holidays bro when
like that's the thing but right now
i care but i don't care but if we had
something booked
are we go yeah oh yeah as soon as
something's booked yeah well something
booked right now that i know it's going
to be a banging holiday yeah
gasps yeah yeah yeah yeah gas i know
what you mean i know exactly what you
mean oh and i'll be gas every day that
we're there bro i've been gassed every
day i'm tired on the last oh 100
knackered on the last day i had a great
time in amsterdam when we went yeah and
that was that was normal that was like
the lights
holidays was great it was great um
marbella had a whale of a time
miami whale of a whale that was a long
time ago very long time miami was nine
years ago
that's embarrassing
um but yeah all the holidays that we've
been on i've had a great time yeah great
time same same stuff i wake up excited
it doesn't even matter if i'm tired yeah
i be far
i beef it was great bro that was fun i
believe it was shattered
i was shattered every day
i was shattered every single day on the
last day the last day in ushuaia my
knees wanted to break bro bro i couldn't
stand up lucky i love him lou i did that
all for him bro because i didn't want to
be there anymore i was in the soul
tired oh there were so many paintings on
the show it was so there was one
painting shows myself standing next to
me i remember i think i remember wedge
hill's titties were just flamboyant
oh she was so beautiful but yeah yeah
that night was always tiring for me i
was exhausted bro exhausted hungry i
remember we were hungry went to where's
that american american spot afterwards
yeah yeah look at your face that was bad
that was my favorite part the whole
night
that's the sign of my age boy yeah yeah
yeah the bird party was trash
i felt through
you man don't understand yeah so we went
on a boat we went on a boat party i
think it was it was bird player then a
schwein right it was the same day was it
not yeah it was the same day the worst
day of my life we didn't i was i think
it's just sorry to got you one before
you get into it yeah i was promised a
nap between the two were you i was
promised enough for someone either both
your man or one of you man promise me
enough i told you how tired i was i was
promised a nap between the two
and then two two little vouchers yeah
yeah and they're like let's go now
i wanted to cry bro when we decided that
we weren't sleeping in between those two
things i wanted in my head it was like
cool beau party finishes like the whole
time on the boat i was so tired
and i'm thinking right i can handle this
and i'm hanging as well yeah i'm
thinking right boat party finishes at
like six
get back to the um apartment for like
seven
sleep until like 10 at least and then we
can be out by 11. yeah yeah uh till
i don't care anymore i don't care
anymore bro
finish the thing at six check the timer
said we need to be in before seven yeah
we had to go straight there
usually i was empty when we got there
but that was the early betting that's
the reason
free free entry signs
and it was like a hundred quid if you
wanted to get in like a normal time yeah
i could see why it's 100 [ __ ] nice in
there but
bro
bro yeah you're throwing up thing bro so
yeah itching boat party right we went on
a boat pie during the day before we went
to ushuaia and we've probably spoken
about this before it was the same day
where that chick had the tampon coming
out of her ting and i tried to tell her
babes so for those that i haven't seen i
can't remember what website it was so
we're on the boat party first of all
when you think about a boat pie in ibiza
you think big man i'm going to be on a
yacht we all thought we were going to be
on the yacht there's going to be a pool
in the yard
[ __ ] i think me and martin garrix
were going to be bro here the dj's going
to be lavish this is going to be
volleyball there's gonna be all sorts
there's gonna be all sorts on this yacht
i thought there's gonna be a pool in the
middle
it was the smallest dingiest [ __ ]
it was the shittest thing i've ever been
on
it was the shittest thing i've ever been
on i was like [ __ ] my life we already
signed up for it let's go on we went on
this thing now
so like i said this was the same this
was the same day that
um there was i think two either jordi
yats or i think they were geordi i think
they were geordie um two of them one
they were they weren't that good looking
for me but no they were totally
different they weren't and then one of
them had a tampon on him because a
string was running down her leg
it was just so embarrassing
she wasn't a black bikini all black
bikini makes sense now because she was
on a period yeah and he had a string
running down her leg
and i saw him and i think i told you man
i was like you did have to tell her i
got it i have to tell her
so i went up to where obviously music's
loud we're in the ocean there's a
there's different ambiance and i wrapped
my hand around her neck to whisper in
her ear she thought i was moving to her
she was giddy she was down she wrapped
her hand around my neck i was like babes
i need to let you know
the string is hanging now
the string is hanging out we can all see
it we can all see if you oh she got
she's like thank you she told that girl
i'm dipped to the toilet
dip to the toilet if i said i'd jump off
the boat
that shame
i couldn't show my face on it on deck
again at that point now she had realized
everyone had seen it
everyone had seen it hey man i'm not
showing my face on on on the port ever
again i'm leaping
i'm swimming back for sure
needless to say after that happened fam
the boat was rocking
i realized on that day i get seasickness
because broski
i hadn't really drank that much we
hadn't really eaten that much that day
we had nothing
this was our last this was our second to
last day yeah so we were all exhausted
right
it was already a [ __ ] boat i was we
weren't down it was two floors we were
on the ground floor and everyone was
doing like liquid activities upstairs i
could hear the mic man and everyone
going crazy i was i'm sitting downstairs
because i'm not here for this anymore as
soon as i stepped on a but i already
knew i'm not having fun so i'm not even
going to pretend
i'm not going to pretend the boat was
rocking we were far into the sea as well
so we couldn't tell man to go back then
man were doing jet skis and what and i
was like nah man i'm sweating fam
and the toilet was busy every man was
going through that one toilet every man
was bopping into that one as soon as i
saw it free
scurried in there fam i threw the [ __ ]
up when i got back if you man could see
the sweat you were so that was running
down my face
honest to god i thought someone had just
dashed
that's exactly what you said you said
big man you look like you've just come
back from jet ski because i was soaked
you were dripping wet man humans can't
sweat like that i perspire
sometimes you were sweating through your
head
physically couldn't believe it bro worst
worst afternoon of the worst day of my
life
and then we went to ushuaia and my knees
were killing me that day oh
oh my days i've never wanted to sleep so
bad
i wish we came to the i wish we all came
together as men at the beginning of the
bow pie before we took off and said guys
let's get off this ain't it you just
disaim it i know we've paid our money
but we we all know what's best let's get
off let's go back to bed eat kip and go
ashwire at six seven oh have a nice day
at the hotel maybe another little dip
some pre-drinks at yard and then we'll
hit ushuaia
that we should we didn't think we should
have taken our wristbands and [ __ ] tough
yeah ah we didn't think because there
were thick there was only one afternoon
we chilled in the hotel and had a dip
and that's when we saw like those three
girls that our neighbors do you remember
yeah yeah i remember the pool was warm
the pool was warm and we had like we had
a couple decent neighbors that we were
talking to you were talking to i was
talking i don't talk to people like that
gee i was i was happy for you but i
wasn't talking to anyone but yeah i
remember we had a good afternoon one
time so i was like why don't we do that
again
we did an italian spot next door even
though we're in spain there was like an
italian joint next to us that served a
bang i would never get a bang in a
bolognese was
that bolognese didn't make sense you
would have bought these and i think uh
lewis or the carbonara i can't remember
what you ordered i think you ordered a
carbonara and i remember thinking the
brit the brit in me was like there's no
way i'm ordering italian food
they're brittany you're so stubborn the
british are there's no way i'm ordering
that because i don't know what the [ __ ]
that tastes like and you were saying
this banging he was at this car but i
was banging i think ordered a burger and
chips you must keep it basically
unless it's unless we're in that level
of cuisine yeah yeah if we're in china
i'll load the chinese yeah yeah if we're
yeah if we're somewhere in italian
restaurant yeah in like israel
burger and chips please or pizza it's
sucking flat yeah so i'm basic
because i just i fear for my life and
then kind of things first um i'm not
gonna lie to you the bolognese didn't
make sense yeah that's cool
i'm glad i never forget i'm glad i'm
glad it makes no sense i'm glad i'm glad
i remember i ordered a lasagna and i
nappa where's my cake in my life really
worth myself probably the reason why you
didn't go i was hesitant to do it then
yeah i did it and i wanted to dash it
it was sludge
it was absolute sludge and then i
remember the girl i was with at the time
she was like send it back and i'm like i
can't send it there's nothing wrong with
it yeah it's just
like it's just grim for me you can tell
it's not undercut it's not like that
this is the way you can tell it came out
exactly as they wanted it to come out
yeah yeah yeah this is exactly how they
wanted it to be so if i send it back
what am i supposed to do yeah because
they because then like i don't like when
people are like
i'll send it back and just order
something else
oh i don't like that sen that's your
fault yeah if you don't like it this is
yours if there's something wrong with it
send it back and i'll send you a new one
that doesn't have that thing wrong with
it replacement as a replacement exchange
yeah my girl's telling me oh send it
back and just order a steak instead i
was like that's a pistol that's a piss
take i get it because i i know i
understand yeah i was like i'll hold
this l it's my fault i didn't want to
order a design for some crazy reason i
ordered it
i don't even know lasagna in england
i don't know what you've never ordered
a flamboyant feeling
it can happen yeah yeah lasagna at
sunset
i was on poxy date iron upper
flipping albums horrible so yeah and the
man came out vex these foreign men don't
like them they don't eat their food they
don't there's no etiquette for them
there's no etiquette chef came out said
what's wrong with it that's a bit i said
i just don't like it what's wrong with
it
[Music]
leave me alone that's hilarious it's
fine there's nothing wrong with it i'm
just not hungry
girls women if you're
if you're
on a date or having food with another
woman or with a woman and as a man you
don't like the food the woman is going
off at the restaurant 100 especially if
you go toilet it's like their fault it's
a fam they want the best for you it
doesn't matter how it happens
they'll ruin your night getting the best
service possible for you women love
doing that we appreciate you doing that
for us as well but it's like sometimes
just leave it just leave it stop but we
know you mean well yeah yeah yeah yeah
they want that it's best for you that's
just not on
they treat waiting stuff like [ __ ]
getting you what you deserve
we're here for a reason let them know so
send it back and get a steak that's a
piss tank it's not even in the same
field of maine it's nothing the same
that's a lasagna or steak wow
bro um right
just a rap yeah uh i've got a final
request pause need to piss again you
need your prostate checked it's what you
need g
right so fan request yeah yeah
hey guys i've got a situation
i've just completed 18 months of
celibacy
wow
bro
she's a female by the way i was about to
ask is it male or female
um first year was very good and healing
i reconnected with can you imagine bro
i bet i reconnected with my body and
realized some negative patterns the last
six months i've remembered what i'm
missing
i bet you have [ __ ]
it's a female you said female her [ __ ]
must have been tingling at anything she
could see a man just walking down the
street tight jeans were a no-go dude
um so after 18 months uh would you wait
for someone
uh
stroke date for a bit
um
bit of commitment okay would you wait
for someone date stroke bit of
commitment or go straight in for the
kill
i think i already know the answer but i
wanted another opinion i don't want to
ruin my progress but also it's a human
need i hear that i hear both worth
noting i have a free house coming up in
the next few weeks so there's lots of
temptation
bro bro
knowing me right
let's say i have completed 18 months of
celibacy yeah yeah the
first the first few months or weeks as
it is
of the celibacy would be hell for me oh
yeah hell
i'm assuming she's not like masturbating
or anything i don't know
i'm going to assume she's not i'm going
to assume she's not yeah
because i feel like she wants to take
the celibacy to a whole nother yeah the
thing is as well to be fair if that's
what you're doing then you should just
wrap all of it all of it off you know
there's no point in not [ __ ] but
fingering yourself yeah you're not
[ __ ] wanking off yeah i'm assuming
she's not foreplaying herself whatsoever
so
if she's reached the 18 month mark
that's a like a year a year a month
alone it's too long for me but if i've
reached an 18-month mark i'm thinking
okay
let me actually
because at this point i feel like i've
changed as a human being because i've
found myself i'm
in a different space mentally physically
everything like we said the guy that did
the no fapting on
our patreon episode he went for how long
a few months it was i think he uh i want
to say he did like a hundred days yeah
something stupid like something for a
few months
and he said he was a better person for
it like physically mentally and blah
blah blah and i'm thinking if i've
reached that stage of 18 months i
already know i'm going to be a different
person so
i can only
i can only assume i'd want to
keep it up and then maybe wait for the
right person but the fuji i am today
answering this question today not having
done the 18 months today
oh i'm [ __ ] the first opportunity i
get yeah but you know so it all depends
on
it all depends on the mindset because i
know for a fact that if you ask me today
ah i've got free art all week next week
or whatever
let's run from let's run some things
through and have fun
i'm going to have fun you know bro
but if i've been on the celebrity thing
i don't know i feel like if i'd been on
that celebrity thing and i was ready to
go
i'd be like
you know
you know in like movies and stuff where
they they like
someone gets like captured and tortured
and stuff
and then the first bit they just can't
handle it anymore yeah yeah to the point
where they just snap yeah and they're
just like laser focused and then they'll
just kill someone with like their one
hand and just bash them and stuff like
that yeah yeah yeah and they can just
like
see bullets and [ __ ] yeah every life is
different bro i feel like the first few
months i will be scratching my eyes out
yeah and then after a while i'll just be
laser focused yeah and then you see the
world differently bro see the world
differently and like i feel like
the time that i'm ready to smash someone
i need to inform police i need to inform
someone what's going down yeah sign some
kind of contract yes yes some concerns
because if i let the beast out yeah i
don't know what's going to happen yeah
because it needs to be a team that likes
dick because she's about to guess she's
going to get more than she ever asks for
bro
she's going to be walking out
yeah i understand completely like i'm
i'm trying to drag around by her ankles
like it's gonna be long for her it's
long step over and more bro long for her
i know exactly what you mean and then
when you finish just like
ah you're gonna see blue blue again
you can see color yeah everything was
black and white yeah yeah yeah so i
think so but i would definitely going
for the kill go for the curve because i
reckon
for me i reckon it would be when she
said i'll look at the date or something
like that i think
it would be such a distraction
like the fact that i haven't banged
anyone in 18 months if i'm like looking
to date someone stuff like that bro if
i'm seeing some soft skin or something
i'm thinking all i want to do is smash
bro let's get these three dates out the
way yeah that's what i want to do that's
all i can think about yeah
so i'll go straight for the kill just
clear my head and then then i can start
looking today ruiner you i know for a
fact i wouldn't let cause obviously we
don't not wanked nothing like 18 months
i
i'd be so livid because i know i'd bust
so quick
but i'd also within that five minutes 10
minutes region
i would absolutely be like
her yeah a lifetime
lifetime of banging i would eat pum like
i've never eaten pun before oh bro like
i'm like i'm a starved refugee well i
would want to eat her from the inside
out yuck but i know you know what i'm
saying though i'd be in there for time
before i stick it bro because i've
missed it ah
i'll be missing
edamame beans out of the battery hole
farm
popping them in my mouth anything bro oh
and
anything and everything 18 months bro
that's the pup to be fair that's the
perfect time if someone wanted to like
experiment with me just like eating
about your finger with me whatever
whatever
after 18 months do what you want to be
eight after 18 months off you know
do what you want to me bro because i
want to know
i don't care how it happens i just want
to like yeah we get edgy obviously
because you know what it feels like when
you know and obviously you know what it
feels like when i know like my optimum
climax so let's say because it's been 18
months and they do do the thing about
the body for you and the nut is
wilder than you've ever imagined heroin
it's crack cocaine yeah on steroids
it's like wow
would you then after that first
experimentation for like 10 minutes or
whatever
would you then be down to do that again
or would you leave it because you've
done it you've tried it you can say
you've taken off the box you're not
going to try again what would you do oh
now fam she'll walk in my face will be
on the
bed my ass will be six feet in the air
we're going again fam let's do that
again arched
six feet in the air
oh that's amazing yeah like a yacht milk
me
milk me
[Laughter]
ah i could have read it it's so horrible
i could already imagine it you said
you're you're six weeks she's sucking up
from the back bro my face will be flat
i'll be on my tippy toes
[Laughter]
[Music]
stilettos on everything
that is hilarious oh yeah 100 bro if it
was spectacular like that
sexy speck nah bro oh
face plant the bed i know exactly what
you yap me
well i hope i feel like we've did we
even answered the question or you go for
it yep basically yeah go for it yeah
yeah go for it go get it out of the
system and then you can take someone to
you you need to because if you yeah if
you go on that first date you're
distracted he's coming back to the yard
you're hanging here especially because
you say you've got a free off a few
weeks yo all you're going to want to do
is fight nando's will spiral out of
control
[Music]
as [ __ ] for you
best of luck best of luck man uh guys
thank you thank you for listening thank
you for tuning in
make sure you like subscribe comment all
of that good stuff the merch as well
flying off the shelf don't forget
season three summer merch
okay go check that patreon in the dms
it's the first time i've never ever said
patreon oh [ __ ] yeah patreon patreon.com
forward slash she's just getting gigs
jump in enjoy
episode every thursday
catch the next one
[Music]
you